Guys, this is a good comment,
so don't hate on her for asking.
She says, what happens when,
just like your boss, he finds you no longer valuable?
She's talking about my husband.
We've all heard the horror stories of men
leaving their wives with absolutely nothing
when all they've done is stay home for decades raising children.
The truth is, the statistics now
is that 70 to 80% of all divorces are initiated by women.
And that number goes up to 90% if they are college educated
or have a degree. This is important
because I feel like there's a lot of fear mongering
when it comes to marriage
and becoming a stay at home mom
because we feel like we're putting down our lives
and we're ruining our resumes
and there's nothing we can go back to when if the man pulls the plug.
But the truth is, it's really unjustified to even have that fear
when it's really women that are leaving the most marriages,
not men. Now, yes,
I have heard of men, you know,
sometimes taking everything from a woman.
A lot of the times it's they cheated
and it's still the woman who's initiating the divorce,
not the man. I think there's also way to be smart about this.
I got a degree very young
and my parents knew that I wanted to be a wife and a mom.
And I just got the degree to have in my pocket now.
Yes, that's a Safety net that most of us want or desire.
But the truth is, if you pick a good man from the beginning,
then none of this is an issue.
It's all a meet point. At the end of the day,
there are so many more women
that take almost everything that a man works for
and they take his children and his home.
I live in a communal state.
We Teeter taught between Mexico and Texas.
And let me tell you, at the end of the day,
almost every judge is gonna side with me.
Quite frankly, I don't think that's completely fair.
Especially when women are leaving marriages
because they just don't feel satisfied anymore
or emotionally. There.
I have a ton of other videos on this.
Go scroll my page. But at the end of the day,
women are way more protected than men.
And this fear mongering
we have around being a stay at home mom and a wife
is really, again,
just unjustified. Again,
I've seen some in real life,
but for the most part
this is really coming from Hollywood and bad rap songs.
There's also things that you can do to be very smart about this.
My husband's building a business and he will make me an employee of it.
When I am 65, I will qualify for Medicare,
Social Security, and all the things that a normal working person would.
You live in a communal state like New Mexico or Texas.
Guess what You already are entitled
to half of what y'all come into the marriage with
and build together. I have never once felt endangered in my marriage
if he even was to consider leaving me.
But again, back to my main point.
The main reason we have all this bad narrative about men
is because women don't choose the right ones
at heart, and I'm speaking from experience.
We're a little bit toxic. Want the toxic love and the UPS and the downs.
And then we sometimes get pregnant by men that we shouldn't,
and we merge our lives with someone that we shouldn't.
I bow my knee to him only because I know who he bows his knee to.
Find a good man, find an honorable man,
and you won't have these issues.
But at the end of the day,
we look past 90% of the good men.
I know that truth stings a little bit,
but it's something that I had to realize,
too, as I was getting older into my thirties.
So with that said, thank you for this comment.
I absolutely don't blame you for asking.
I explain this a lot to my nieces and the younger women around me.
Sometimes
we just have to sit back and look at how truly indoctrinated we are
as a society and as a culture
that makes women fear a relationship in a nuclear family so much.